Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE is weighing in
on the missing whistleblower or informant who is
fingering Joe Biden with crimes. As Larry Kudlow
said, she doesn't care that there's no evidence,
she doesn't care that the whistleblower is
missing. Marjorie Taylor GREENE believes that
the whistleblower will end the presidency
of President Joe Biden. Listen to this.
Speaker 4: They're whistleblowers. Yes,
they are missing. They're either in court,
they're in jail, or we cannot talk with
them at this time because they can't be
found. This is a very real situation that we're.
Speaker 1: It's very real, except there's no
evidence and the people making the claims are
missing. But it's totally real talking about.
Speaker 4: And our investigation is so important,
Steve. This will bring down the president of the
United States. And I want to let everyone
know something. Going back to the Treasury
Department today at 1:00, okay, because we have
more financial records that we have to review
leading to the Biden family and Joe Biden himself.
Speaker 1: Is it possible that the whistleblowers
were evaporated by the Jewish space laser run by
Soros and Klaus Schwab or whoever is in control of
the thing? You know, they should really put Mike
Pillow in charge of the whole whistleblower thing.
If Mike Pillow were in charge, it would just
be two more weeks until we get all of the
whistleblowers, evidence and testimony, naturally.
Of course, it would be perpetually two weeks until
we got it, but at least it would be only two
weeks. You know, these people, it it is funny
when you see Marjorie Taylor GREENE space and she
she's pretending to see or maybe she is seriously
saying this whistleblower is going to be the end
of the presidency. This is going to be it for Joe
Biden. He's not going to be able to survive this.
There is a funny component. I admit there's a
funny component. But these are people who for
generations have said we are the party of law
and order and yet forget about evidence of crimes
without even probable cause, without reasonable,
articulable suspicion, without a single document
that we might count as evidence, without even the
whistleblower. The whistleblower is missing. She
can say with a straight face, this is going to be
the end of Joe Biden's presidency. And if it were
up to them, they would have already removed Biden,
despite the fact that Biden has done nothing to
make himself worthy of removal from the office of
the presidency. That's really the scary thing.
And tens of millions of. Americans at minimum
have fallen for it. And they may reelect they may
reelect Marjorie Taylor GREENE in 2024. They may
put Trump back in the White House in 2024. And so
the takeaway here is we cannot put our guard down.